what up anime fans its goals then kid
card and kick I we're talking about
Dragon Ball super episode episode 48 and
49 yeah we kind of missed out on the
last two weeks due to work obligations
and a few other things well yeah like
and we also did those special videos the
anime skits and stuff so that took more
time than like average videos right but
we're back and we're making up for the
missed weeks by having two episodes 0
and I will try to keep it more regular
the installments and as you can see
we're doing a different format you guys
can see us what up you can see our
awesome girl logon wall scroll and also
we're the best asalu time of like oh
poop and kick I was funny cake I was
saying that the design for Blanco who is
second alike well no surprise would kick
guys favorite characters Goku so yeah
and the famine was almost redundant like
you know what I meant what I meant to
say is I like his clothes i like the way
is key energy and blaster design and
stuff like that yeah I am actually kind
of disappointed that they're just
recycling characters in their images no
this is this is actually interesting I
want to see what happens who this black
go cool guy is right because you know
what maybe it's like recycling maybe
this isn't in his true form but it
creates mystery like why does he look
like Goku that we're gonna be asking we
could keep asking and yeah I think it's
interesting what I didn't think what i
thought was weird was when after trunks
narrowly gets away and then all a sudden
BAM uh my cocoa takes out a ring and
that is able to transport back in time
like it's nothing that was kind of weird
me and i thought it was interesting how
boom i was going to fix the machine get
more fuel so you can go to the future
and they were going to be in the future
now
be a cool setting for a change kick I
noted that before but no black opal just
comes through and it seems kind of like
weird how quickly he's coming to Earth
right because all of a sudden I thought
like you know this is just the beginning
of the arc and then also in band there
already all of the main fighters are
together it's weird i wonder what
they're gonna do a things are very much
for us you're pacing with this stuff
sometimes it's getting into the point
where it's a bit ridiculous hands is
this gonna be like final like this is
gonna be like a short arc or is it just
gonna be like they're gonna fight now
some is gonna happen they're gonna train
more yeah I think that's what's gonna
happen is they're gonna fight now you
might get his butt whooped and milk
train and stuff because remember we
still have the whole introduction of the
green KY that we see in the beginning
opening theme like we still know nothing
about him the time ring may be tied to
him we just still don't know what's up
the power earrings are and I mean even
if they are pitar earrings because they
look like it but in their University may
not be yeah it's true but I'm definitely
definitely excited see that green guy
though I don't know why I just something
about that green kya interests me I'm
just gonna have fun like just seeing
like how these new gods like that I've
introduced in this dragon ball super I'm
gonna deal with the whole situation
because like Buse and we haven't really
seen them react yet right it was very H
like purposely didn't show them and
their reaction and we have no idea how
they're going to react so that's going
to be interesting to see but I mean who
knows do you think the guys stay out of
it do you think I could try to help with
anything well the thing is I think the
situation is going to get bad to the
point where and on Dominic is going to
make another appearance one thing I want
to know about black Goku is
as many many many people still think
he's a saying I think they're not enough
evidence that that he's not a sin yes
Vicki here inside he he's exterminating
the race by killing Trump's so that
makes him sound right did he even said
something along the lines of how
pathetic um how pathetic it is for a
proud for San where your race too unlike
this or something right before you try
to kill Future Trunks and the situation
haha I just fight with the chair back
guys I usually tell me meters settle
down that's all right well yeah we're
usually using that Mike over there guys
and you know kick I suppose like taps
fingers on a table and you ask adherence
yeah and now they can hear an NCAA and
they can see this lovely yeah it's cool
it's cry it doesn't matter we're about
you like these videos guys like don't
take them too serious I mean it's me and
kick I sharing our thoughts on the
episodes um yeah that's pretty much it
so either like it or not yeah another
thing I want a dress is super trunks
super trucks future trunks there's a lot
weaker than a lot of people anticipated
yeah holy so super saiyan 3 Goku
annihilates him and we haven't even seen
a goku super Sam blue and like little x
kaio-ken and how that's gonna like just
knock trucks out garbage trucks is
giving a prediction that he is around
like goku's maybe slightly started at
Super Saiyan 3 but Super Saiyan God x
time Kyle ken is so superior trunks not
at all astronomers no no he's in black
goku's okay i say glycol who might be
sorry so traffic might be years like
like yeah i'm wondering like what what
does it have a by coconut yeah that's
the whole argument of that power scaling
claim that you're
wondering lake here we go again it was
interesting how trunks got lucky I
avoided the whole majin buu incident by
defeating the boron yeah so that was
interesting I they did that at the
butterfly effect I like work differently
in that timeline that it did in you know
the present DBZ DBS timeline but yeah I
don't know I'm still the guys I'm
missing my man and and the fact that now
they're thinking of going to like they
were thinking going to the future with
trunks to fight um Blanco who does that
mean a trunks trunks is bull my trunks
admire always gonna be dead I think
that's a valid suck because I is he
gonna be alone in that world except for
some random humans yeah because there's
no Dragon Balls apparently their
universe because he's surprised to see
Goku were alive when he realizes that
it's coke would I'm sure there are no
bad dry mouth it's a theory that there's
no because he surprised he Goku which
would imply that he's not aware of the
Dragon Balls existence no I feel like he
is it's josie still so surprised
locational dragon so you can use dragon
pulse with pushback boma and my yeah
actually essentially buddy and I
shouldn't use it it's just because um
piccolo whose fused with call me and the
drug balls are tied in with the
namekians that their stone but that
doesn't mean they can't use present part
we don't know war you know okay so I
present times they could wish for boa in
the future oh [ __ ] goes down the girl is
used per una from namak I'm stronger
than shutter on yes if there is a manic
in that future it has a bit as right
three more or present I'm never
yeah that not all that stuff works there
may be some kind of punishment towards
the end of a night time traveling too
because like if you um in xenoverse they
introduced a chi of time and she
punishes future trunks for making if
we're using the time machine and he
attends a binger servant or something
like that me helps around the time nest
and stuff like that so we may end up
getting with the introduction of more
Kai's we may end up seeing some sort of
kind of time who controls yeah who are
god of time or something because I don't
know they might be separate races a
positive thing about this episode was
they made me think again about how
awesome giant ball z was just that whole
idea of trucks coming in the whole idea
of cell like the whole idea of people
not even knowing with GF boom are gonna
get together and just throwing that in
there like that was pretty well this is
why sell song is my favorite and like
we're definitely channeling some of that
here in this part of dragon ball super
so hope it keeps up I feel like they're
overdoing the humor cuz I don't feel
like I mean over lucre they were a
little bit of like light-hearted humor
with Goku like usually but like you I
feel like they're overdoing it out I
don't think I don't know I don't feel
like I don't really enjoy that you were
like a lot of these dragon ball super
reviewers like yeah yeah I love it I'm
not really loving their dry I don't know
I don't like the humor but the thing is
like they're trying to do a dragon ball
style which was less serious more
comedic than joining ballsy and to be
fair but dragon ball did have to be fair
much better actually quality heuer them
like it was actually good humor as
opposed to this which is not and Dragon
Ball Z i mean that's that's what
captivated most of us that's all we're
here to LA like those are dry ballsy
fans are the ones who are watching this
so yeah I do feel like like the jokes
they're like not as funny and to
prevalence characters I don't my first
I don't like peel off or shoe kid my I'm
still confused why the hell they're kids
I can't remember it likes an explanation
I like she's acting all shy it's tough
and she's like supposed to be an adult
woman she's an adult woman and she's I
when I don't Bowl and she's shy when I
kid holds her hand that's weird and the
Dalek on earth day is getting older so
clearly he is getting older all the rest
of them were like kids oh that's that's
strange as well but ma'am I from the
future though cool my god I miss ya yeah
you missed a character the HUD like 10
seconds of airtime this is all good
dragon ball super is I take the best
care or just kill them off right away
it's all we're left with the other yeah
yeah cuz my eye is clearly the most
character yeah yeah but yeah guys like
pretty much that's our thoughts so far
as I steps as we missed we're glad to be
out of filler and this is interesting
stuff and I can't wait to see where it
goes i can't wait to see who Blanco who
is and I just I hope trunks get strong I
hope he levels up so you can compete as
a Z fighter alongside go Cleo gee I hope
so too but the thing is with the blue
hair and then the Super Saiyan God how
is the little look yeah that's the
question how do you mean super saiyan
blue this whole blue hair thing cuz of
the manga thing make it makes sense I
guess but like why not make a little
trunks blue like I was he gonna look
yeah yeah yeah I'm not saying s go super
saiyan 3 i'm saying how is he gonna look
if you already has blue hair is just
going to go up like its gonna look like
he's just powering up like that's the
question yeah it was a bad idea by the
animations to know we'll see like we
can't hundred percent say that until we
see what happens all right now it's
looking like he's like Irish roots in
blue so that's gonna be a shame but
whatever who cares we'll see what
happened you may
oh I just love contradicting him hey
guys be naked guy has said it kid Kai
has or at least hasn't promised shot him
he can't go back to the future being a
bigger eventually yeah so we'll see you
guys I look forward to seeing it and you
know what the next episodes coming out
in a bit so we'll be back at you with a
new episode soon this will be our new
format so you guys can look at cake has
beautiful face until next time see you
later space cowboys
black goku pretty much my thoughts is
that you spike as pic I was like yeah
that's a good haha or scrolled you also
not stickin ah